hey everybody I'm Kristian harloff and
I'm Tiffany Smith from movieclips and
this is our very special edition this is
our spoiler heavy review uh Star Wars
The Force awakens as long as we can so
they know let's talk about this movie as
far as what you like give me some of the
things that you really enjoyed about
someone first of all did you like the
movie I loved the movie it was
everything that I wanted if I'm getting
nitpicky there were little things that I
would want to achieve absolutely but
this feels like a Star Wars film Star
Wars is back it did everything seemed
lived in just like the original trilogy
and JJ made a point of doing that there
are a lot of practical effects there's
only one usage of CGI that really
bothered me in this movie and it's when
Han Solo right before he gets the ha the
Millennium Falcon back you know in the
originals when they do the job of stuff
with CGI and a lot of people didn't like
it it felt like it did feel like it's
not like special edition yeah but they
got away from it yeah the other thing I
will say about that scene though that
bummed me out a little bit was the fact
that we have the actors from the raid in
this movie we'd heard so much about them
getting cast and I was expecting to see
these epic battles with them and it was
in and out really quick yeah we don't
know necessarily if they helped
choreograph some of the fights or things
happen too but yeah you're right there
are a couple people I think that's just
look this is what we'll do first we'll
hit on some of the things maybe we
didn't like first course we're gonna
gush about it a little later you talked
about how the raid guys were underused
there were two other people I thought
were underused one of those was Maximus
yeah I knew those up gives a great
speech to kind of read about final Luke
Skywalker the Jedi to Poe sorry to PO
about Luke Skywalker and then he's just
dead kylo kills him it's over you're out
captain phasma is another one yes in and
then she's out of the movie she's not
dead just out this movie had a lot of
catching up to do because not only is it
30 years between the last film and this
one that they had to catch us up on but
they had to catch us up on all the new
characters they had to catch us up on
where all the characters we know and
love have been for the past thirty years
so some of those scenes and some of
those characters that we didn't get a
ton of time with I feel like it was
because this movie is
building the world and and that's where
I will say it does an incredible job of
it yes that's the point that yeah I
think is the major point here is this
movie is playing for the long game yeah
that's what I loved about it even though
maybe some of the things where I got
started all the way set up they will be
set up in episode 8 and episode 9 and I
thought one of the things they did
really well
Rea Daisy Ridley is I got my rave on
gone dude oh man she is so but she is
for a girl has only been on a set for
two weeks in a lifetime besides this and
I called it on my speculation video that
she was gonna be Luke Skywalker's
daughter and it certainly seems like she
is Luke Skywalker certainly seems that
way because Maz Kanata basically says
the lightsaber found Luke's grandfather
found Luke and then basically found ray
I love that vision of Rey when when it
took us back in a little bit of history
and I loved the opening crawl when you
see if episode 7 and when you see that
this is what's gonna happen and that it
was the movie is about the search for
Luke yeah some people are gonna be upset
that Luke is the very last shot you only
see him I love it I think it sets you up
so well for Episode II and it really
gets you going and the kylo Ren stuff I
thought was handled yeah great I will
say my two favorite characters I think
coming out of this movie would have to
be Poe Dameron and kylo Ren I feel like
for both of them they felt very grounded
in the world and for some of the other
characters it felt like they were still
learning and we got that in the trailer
I'm not saying it wasn't something they
were trying to do because for Finn and
for Rey
it wasn't learning about all this whole
new world again but for those two
characters they've been a part of it
like kylo has been with the first order
for a long time and he knows what's
going down any knows Darth Vader I know
that the force is really a history buff
yeah Poe on the same token like he has
been with the resistance for a while so
he know that the force is real and he
knows what they're really up again kylo
is trying to earn his place and trying
to prove that he really is from the dark
side because he is I don't know if he is
Han oh I'm Lance I'm
only a son for sure and you're like I
don't know if you know you're
referencing Plagueis there's a why I
still want to know there's so many
questions to help that come before like
how kylo Ren was recruited how he turned
to the dark side all that how he left
his parents and this is the major
spoiler right now that that everyone's
gonna be talking about once I've seen
this movie and that is Han Solo um we
thought he was gonna be toast
it's it's kind of a choreographed death
you know that it's coming a little bit
telegraph but it still got me
emotionally because after he goes and
he's just kind of discarded like trash
which is like ah that that was painful
to me but when Chewie starts the
crossbow and taking everybody out and
then Finn and Rachel just met Han really
they have an emotional attachment to
that was a goodbye to a character and by
the way I also said that Holloway
wouldn't be together in this and you
told me I was not you're right ah I
think that that was something for me
that would have made losing Han even
more emotional if they had still been
back if they were still felt it though
that god I love how she tuned into the
horse by the way that's the other thing
they don't talk about that okay with
that we don't know what hurt if she got
trained at all we don't know if she
really knows how to use the force in any
stronger of a way than when we see Han
die and you flash to her because she's
not there it's not like they have comms
in saying what's going on but she looks
in the camera and you're just like which
I will say Carrie Fisher on the carpet
has been kooky pants but in this movie
level she is layout she is general Leia
all the characters are general and I
thought Akbar did the best job of
returning talked about in the opening
crawl that it is the search for Luke the
first order has taken over and they're
like the only way to balance the force
is to find the last Jedi yeah who is
Luke Skywalker who when he left was
training a bunch of new Jedi
including Ben solo it's very similar to
what happened with obi-wan Kenobi and
Dorothy mm-hm as where Anakin went off
on the dark side and wiped out all the
Jedi it looks like kylo Ren Ben went to
the other side and wiped out all the
Jedi as well and now Luke's on his own
personally I think that Ray has been a
strong Jedi for a
long time I think that's why she's able
to tap in to the force really easy yeah
that's why she's so good with the
lightsaber I think that Luke was using
some kind of powerful mind trick to keep
her hidden to keep her powers hidden and
it's coming back to her like wow I don't
even know if it was that she because she
didn't believe in it she didn't know it
was there and so it's like sometimes
when you think about there's something
there that's always been helping you but
you're unaware of it but once you're
aware and you can tap into it that's
when everything starts happening because
yes she is pretty clever she can find
things she is a great scavenger she's a
great fighter and that's without her
knowing she can tap into the force one
of the questions for me is obviously
what happens with ray and Luke ray is
there is it is Luke Ray's father is he
going to become her teacher what is
gonna happen well definitely gonna
become her teacher you think absolutely
I think the big question is who the
Freak is supreme leader snoke right and
what is the relationship to kylo Ren
what does he want yeah what does he want
what is his relationship then with
phasma and Huck's because I feel like we
met a lot of these big villains but we
don't know what the driving force behind
all of it is and at the end of the film
Snoke basically says to Huck's get kylo
we need to start working on our next
thing and you're like what is the next
thing yeah another big question that
we're left with is Finn right when the
film ends Rey basically says I hope to
see you again you don't know he's not
awake he's been injured so that to me is
something that's gonna be pretty
interesting I also want to know like
what was going on in his head before
that like yeah I felt like that that
scene to me he's still in the
stormtrooper suit but you you see him
like hesitating and even that moment
when kylo looks at him that I'm like
kylo could have put something into his
was definitely looking into his mind but
it's like who knows what he put in there
or what he saw and just the bloody hand
across his helmet I think was what did
it for him where he's like why are we
slaughtering these people what is going
on here I don't know why I just grew up
into this and he says later on in the
film that this was his first time going
out like that was his first time really
seeing the brutality of the first order
I also want to see what's gonna happen
with Leia we mentioned as far as are we
gonna learn about her force abilities we
certainly see that she can tap into it
still as she feels it went on
like what is her role in all this she
basically leads the resistance which is
a faction of the Republic which we have
found out in this country the Republic
does exist I assume we're gonna learn
more about the Republic and I mean
seeing where Maz Kanata ends up right
her entire castle was destroyed she was
like oh she's brushed it off yeah we see
her she's like go find Rey because she
needs you to fit yeah had she known
where Luke was this whole time and
because she's the one with the
lightsaber and she said I've been
holding on to this right another thing
is Chewie
where's Chewie no no he doesn't seem
like he's going with Rey does he stay
with Leia like where does he go does he
go off on his own is it that's that's a
big question yeah I think something that
a lot of people forget mostly because of
what happened in the pretty cool is that
the original films were really funny
they had really quick one-liners Han
Solo had most of them in this film
there's a lot of characters that
actually have them and one of the
biggest ones that stood out for me was
the moment when kylo and poe dameron
meet for the first time and pose
standing there and they're both looking
at each other and he's like well this is
awkward
who's gonna talk first are you gonna
talk first am I gonna talk that was
really far time for me it's still Han
and Chewie like when Chewie there's in
the end there and on the ice planet and
he's just like oh are you are you cold
like Han says that that really that the
banter that they have I still have it
the humor did work for me Manjari to
this movie the one thing that I was
worried about was a couple times it
seemed like they were just giving lines
to everyone yeah where they should have
maybe like just for character or heavy
on one character and I know what I did
it because Poe was only in the movie for
like the beginning and like the end so
he's not ended enough to give him the
line so then they gave a lot of it to
fin which I thought worked but then
there's han solo there as well and I
just was like okay let's not turn into a
comedy show and they got away from ya so
but I thought the humor did work I think
sometimes it maybe was a little out of
place but overall I'd say that 80% of it
worked oh I have a question yeah what
moment made you get really emotional
don hunting just the Han moment that was
the main that was the main thing too
because even though I saw it coming we
are never going to see him again in a
Star Wars so obviously I gotta say a
massive huge gigantic thank you to JJ
Abrams for this one because
not only was an incredible undertaking
to do he had to make sure that fans were
excited about it after what we had for
the prequels he had to make sure that
people felt like their characters that
they loved were honored when one of the
main one dies it's like to kill a main
character like that is a huge thing to
take on you can tell he's a fan because
he went back and wrote it with Lawrence
Kasdan who wrote Empire Strikes Back
and he went and he and he had these
conversations with him and went to the
true spirit of what Star Wars is you
felt it that it was a love letter even
though there's a lot of similarities
that was so forth it was still a love
letter to the franchise and I think that
that's what JJ Abrams as a screenwriter
as a filmmaker as a fan brought to the
table and thank you for watching our
spoiler heavy review of the force
awakens now it is up to you guys tell us
exactly what you thought of the movie
did you like what didn't you like do it
let us know and before we go I just want
to say a huge huge thank you to JJ
Abrams Disney and lucasfilm's because
mind blown so happy such a Star Wars fan
geek girls peers thank you guys very
much and only one thing needs to be said
you will share this video I don't think
that worked let me check you will share
this video I think that works it did
don't look at me I'm a Jedi what can I
say
[Music]